what do we know about this so far that
tells us what the next step will be I
can't sir hold on a second there's a few
things happening right I have some
suggestions I'd like to factorizing I
need to get to an A and write a general
kind of expression for this but before I
get to a general expression
I haven't established the patent you see
that I don't have enough times so
therefore for part two the very first
thing I must do is any three okay that's
where I've got to begin now the
advantage of having written this is
because if I write that right then a
three is going to start out in exactly
the same way except there will be a tree
there and this guy will be bigger
because again every single month
Joe increases the size that did initial
deposit yeah sorry increases the size of
the deposit so therefore I'm going to
begin with the previous amount I get a
new deposit here but it's one percent
bigger than this right so it's going to
be 500 times 1.01 square right under 1%
of that there's the first statement
wasn't and then the second thing which
is the interest calculation yeah okay
let's extend again that is a two so I'm
going to write this all out to see years
looks let me see yes you mean that well
why did I in the husband yes okay great
great question art and let me just
mention this again right please please
please I mean I'll show you my working
with their full working in the same way
you saw a little end up staring this is
we the wall of numbers you must see
through the numbers to what every single
thing means right so in fact I mean that
this is one of our mission of examples
maybe it is worth doing it on this like
here I'm going to write this I'm going
to say what are each of these things
right so this is the first depositor
right and what it gets is two interest
calculations because it's been sitting
there for two months right so this is
two months of features yeah this is the
second deposit here this whole thing I
put that up curly brace there so that
you can see the 1.01 comes with like its
start of that big it's bigger and then
here is one month of interest yeah
now if we understand that then we come
here we'll understand why this is -
right what does this represent this is
the third deposit YZ or not I feel like
every sink some
that's it that's that's it - isn't it
yeah there we go
I got quite okay I'm missing the newest
one which is this the one in the first
line so because I was halfway through
explaining so you can see there's that
first deposit right three months of
interest when I multiply this through
there's the second deposit here's the
third deposit the third deposit is
bigger than the previous two it's
exactly one percent bigger right soo see
how he's the first one 500 he is the
second one one percent bigger and here's
the third one it's one percent big up
again right and every time I go a
subsequent month it's going to get
bigger to stop so this is not about time
and like oh it's been in there it's
getting interest this is about the fact
that Joe wants to make it deposit this
increasingly large each time okay
there's just any more money so she's
putting more money differently alright
so now I've because I was hopping around
like mr. term let's actually extend this
out and that will be enough to establish
our patent so I've got 500
and he's the great thing if you're
invested see this stuff that I've
written in red so you like you know what
the numbers mean then here I'm not even
going to do the algebra I'm not going to
just expand at these terms I'm just
going to think about each deposit and
how much stuff is going on so there's
three months of interest I've read that
and look at those numbers and I see
three months of interest and then I look
at this and I say well that was the
second man so it better have two months
ago this is been even there for that
long right and then he comes out last
amount it's bigger right and it's had
one month to stay in there and actually
gets sorry okay does that make sense you
see how obviously I'm not gonna keep on
writing this every single time but at
the beginning please please like you got
to know what these numbers actually
stand for they're not just numbers it
will save you some pain later you know
if you get out to the world okay
should everybody know I want to hear
from this which is a 3-2 some kind of am
right to make it a bit clearer as has
been mentioned before there's some
common stuff I can take out this for
instance is a 500 every single time
right so I'm going to take that out
okay now I'll talk about that in a
second I have blood from the last two
minutes that I'm not going to turn an
answer a question while I finish writing
my line side of us in terms so I'll
answer that direct question and I'll
show you what my answer is No
okay so I took out the factor of 500 you
can see I could have taken out the
factor of one point zero zero three as
well if I wanted to okay the reason that
didn't is for two reasons number one as
it turns out it does not end up making
errors and simply like I know that seems
it's strange like that isn't taking out
numbers gonna be easier the answer is
well no it's not because everything is
still going to be just as long right
secondly what I want to preserve is that
when I read this I see three months
interest like I look at that and that's
what I interpret it as if I took a one
point zero zero three out that kind of
clouds it kind of obscures what's going
on it's like is it 3-1 series at two
months well it's three months but it
says two because I took one of the
months out that's a big confusion
remember okay so I leave that in there
so that it means what it means
all right now I'm ready now
to generalize now is interesting but
this particular question if I didn't
want to any time to do this step I could
just write a 60 if I wanted to it okay
however I'm going to do this step now
because frequently plot to be writer
generals they then 4k events need to
work that muscle so the easiest part is
I will start with a 500 and now think
about this right so I've been going or
joy been going for 10 months right so
what will this first term be think about
it it is the very first depositor and
it's been in there for 10 months so you
see this is why the advantage of not
taking it around so clearly this is just
going to be that first amount and it's
got em lots of interest adding on to it
yeah
the next term alone will be the second
deposit right now the second deposit it
started at pickup one point one time to
pick up but it hasn't been in as long
it's been in there for one month straw
so that's why this would be one point
zero zero three to that and minus one
okay anyone else what up and then I can
sort of continue the pattern right the
next one will be bigger again but it
will be in there for a shorter amount of
time
okay now that's the first three terms
dot dot dot what will the master be now
you can look and you borrow the last
term of the pattern and you use that as
your path okay so you have a look at
this
when is this number this one pointer one
and have to where does it come from
do you see do you see get some one less
exactly one less than however many
months you've been in does that make
sense because you've had this one which
is bigger and this one which is bigger
again so how much bigger is the enth
deposit the answer is so we in your
you're thinking in those particular
terms for 16 here it's gonna be at minus
one degree with that and I'm looking at
three and I see two I look at two and I
see one does that make sense
you see how the pattern
last thing is this is the end deposit
but interest gets added in luck so it's
going to have one lot of interest on it
so far so good
okay so this is nice right this thing
here right this is a GP now what defines
this GP the first it's easy the first
term at least in the way that I've
written it the first term he is yeah
that guy the end lots of interests that
attach to the first deposit right so
it's going to be a equals 1.0 okay but
then when you get to the next thing when
you look at the common ratio hmm this is
not really as simple as what we've seen
before
okay because have you written out like
this you can kind of see it's a little
bit like I hope you remind you of
binomial remember binomial and there's
like this time in that term and what it
mean creases in power and the other one
decrease in how do you recall that
enough so you got exactly the same thing
here do you see from this term to this
term I had done two things
I'm multiplied by something and I've
divided by something jeans you see that
right so in the one point where one it's
multiplying but what you divide by all
the way up until the end right every
time you're dividing by one point zero
zero three and that's what brings its
power down increasing so there is the
ratio and you can see why people perform
poorly on this in the agency it's
confused
so I'm sorry a hundred percent is one
point zero zero so 10 percent is zero
point one zero so one percent is 0.01
because this right is 0.3% not three
percent it's quite pretty exact so it's
gonna go one more time okay first that
last term's tend to be most useful to me
when I'm dealing with babies rather than
GPS like that's what I can use the
formula there's the last right because
that's when you do the pairing thing but
with with GPS you have to go for a ratio
you must go for the ratio because
there's no common difference so they
were just all kids allowed there's a
common ratio which doesn't do that white
last bit how many terms are there it's
easy there has to be interns because
they're in deposit every term is a
deposit does that make sense